من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
اهلا بك الياس ما يرصد من تحركات للجيش
الاسرائيلي هناك على الحدود وما تتمكن من
مشاهدته من موقعك لما يحدث في غزه
الان من الواضح بان المعارك ما زالت ضاريه
والاشتباكات على اشدها في حي الشجاعيه
وكذلك في جباليا هذا ال المخيم الذي قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيانه المسائي يوم
امس انه سيطر عليه من الناحيه العملات لكن
واضح بان الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه
الثقيله والخفيفه في الدقائق الاخيره حملت
معها تاكيدا على ان هذه الاشتباكات ما
زالت مستمره وان المعارك ما زالت قويه
وضاره وتجري وجها لوجه كما اكد اخر بيان
للجيش الاسرائيلي قبل دقائق معدوده حي
الشجاعيه في الساعه الاخيره وكذلك جباليه
لكن تحديد ديدا الشجاعيه والمناطق الشرقيه
من مدينه غزه تعرضت في الساعه الاخيره
لضربات جويه وغارات جويه عنيفه ربما تكاد
غير تكون غير مسبوقه في الايام الاخيره
حتى على اعتبار انها كانت حقيقه هائله
وكبيره ونحن نشاهد هذا الانفجار الان في
المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه
تقريبا في المنطقه الجنوبيه لجحر الديك
غاره جويه عن فه ايضا تطال هذه ال المنطقه
وهذه الغارات التي نشاهد مثلها الان على
الشاشه كانت قبل دقائق معدوده وفي الساعه
الاخيره ايضا قد استهدفت مواقع عده في
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه غزه تحديدا في حي
الشجاعيه وتشاهدون حجم هذا الانفجار
الهائل والقوي الذي اي تنبعث منه سحب
الدخان والاتربه وتتصاعد الى الى ارتفاعات
شاهقه في الجو وهذا يدلل حقيقه على حجم ال
الانفجارات وحجم المواد المتفجره التي
تستخدمها اسرائيل في هذه الغارات الجويه
وبالصو التي تستخدمها في ضرب هذه المناطق
على وجه ال الخصوص من الواضح بان هذه
الغارات اشتدت في ال الساعه الاخيره وهي
حقيقه تكاد تكون غير مسبوقه في في عنفها
وفي في قوتها وفي شدتها لان الانفجارات
حقيقه كانت على مناطقه واسعه في الجهه
الشرقيه ل الشجاعيه ولحق ذلك
ايضا اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه هذا يؤكد
على ان الجنود على الارض ربما يكونوا في
مازق ولكن دعينا فقط نطلب من الزميل لبيب
ان يوجه عدسه الكاميرا ايضا الى المنطقه
القريبه من السياج الامني ونحن قريبون منه
هنا على بعد نحو كيلو متر ونصف تقريبا
ربما تشاهدون عبر الشاشه حجم الضمار
الهائل الذي خ خلفته الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه والقصف المدفعي العنيف الذي
يكاد لا يتوقف وكانه تعمد من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي لتدمير هذه المنطقه السكنيه
القريبه من السياج الامني لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث منذ اسابيع وكذالك
الساسه والعسكر في اسرائيل وكثير من
المحللين السياسيين والعسكريين يتحدثون عن
ان اسرائيل يجب عليها ان تسيطر على حزام
امني اي قرب غلاف غزه يعطيها عمقا
استراتيجيا وعمقا امنيا في حمايه البلدات
الاسرائيليه في الغلاف ومن الواضح بان هذا
التدمير المه الممنهج لهذه المناطق
السكنيه في الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه غزه
وفي الضواحي الشماليه الشرقيه لجبال ينسجم
مع هذه الرؤيه ومع هذه النظره التي تسعى
الى تدمير هذه المناطق واخلاقها من السكان
الفلسطينيين استعدادا للسيطره العسكريه
والناريه عليها من جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي
الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث بالامس في بيانه
المسائي بانه سيطر عملات على جباليا لكن
قبل ساعه راينا بان الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفعي ما زال متركز هناك وهذا يعطينا
فكره على ان المعارك لم تنتهي بعد حتى في
جباليا الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث منذ بدايه
هذا الشهر انه يتقدم ويتوغل ويعمق اي
سيطرته على المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه
لكن من الواضح بان هذه الغارات الجويه لا
تشي بانه حقق هذا المراد حتى هذه الساعه
شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام كنت معنا من
غلاف غزه